[Music]
welcome back to the jury and why do you
have to wear that for what your level
three helmet I'm protected
what would you not wear one if you
thought one this episode of the jaw and
podcast is brought to you by Squarespace
right now guys start your website that
you guys won it's not about going to
squarespace.com slash Jenna Julian save
10% on your first purchase of a website
or domain scores place has 24/7 customer
support and many different templates to
help you start your dream web site you
will not be disappointed
also guys clip the wonderful toothbrush
system that lives in the future
alongside you they send you refuse every
month of brush heads and right now does
it starts at just 25 dollars and you can
get your refill first on us that's all
I'm talking about your first refill of a
brush head for free because you watched
this podcast I'm gonna get quick calm /
annejulien that's get quick calm sauce
Angeline or click the link in the
description I don't even know like where
to look at you cuz I can't see your eyes
I like that you're gonna scare Bob he's
just a little Baba goose I'm gonna
adjust myself also guys we want to give
a quick special shout out to our friends
at SteelSeries who have provided us with
the ultimate gaming materials for all of
our twitch streams and gaming needs they
have officially partnered with our
twitch channel we are steel series
sponsored streamers now it's cuz what
eSports is based on skill alone um my
skill has made it so you know next up
next is I'm gonna get signed and scouted
to an eSports for sure
before we get knock out shroud mm-hmm
guys want to say seriously thank you to
steal serious if you're needing any sort
of gaming equipment headset mouse
keyboard other headset other mouse I
don't know what you need
SteelSeries has some of the best gaming
equipment and peripherals you can buy
and you can save 10% on us my boys just
cracked by using a code gender Julie
intent that's all unofficially
thank you guys we want to give you a
special shout out because you guys are
awesome all right
your daughters being a brat yeah well
you always want to let them in the
podcast I always say no it's fun it's
fun chaos look at her she just wants to
watch just gonna keep working stop the
podcast you're gonna be in trouble lady
just don't step on the keyboard little
guy yeah what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing oh my god can
you hi can you hear me peach oh my god
she's listening good hi peachy girls
really loud for years she's a dog is
that what she's I don't know she was all
these years thank you for telling me
T you're a [ __ ] he are you gonna sit
there the whole time
no it's gonna go well you someone out to
dinner for Julian's brother's birthday
Marlins birthday happy birthday mall in
the hekimae you forever hack on what
days is actual birthday the day the
podcast comes out the 7th okay what's
his sign whatever it is right now what
is it I don't know the what month is it
it's May 7th so that's this birthday hey
Google what sign is May 7th Taurus oh
okay yeah Marlin is the tourist all
right what is it Taurus first no like
like kind of just like even-keeled to
calm she's the most even killed girl
ever met yeah
why is that so dependent or it I don't
know it's like stupid I know I I feel
like all the people just write it off as
nonsense like that's fine you're
entitled to that are you
I've talked about is really crazy turn
into an adult yeah it is like you
realize things about people you're like
oh that actually for some reason makes a
lot of sense yeah usually take on the
qualities of your kind mm-hmm I'm a
Virgo oh yeah welcome to my channel it's
no we wanted to the first of all
something wild happens
what are you scoffing did you say scoff
I know that office joke that's not a
nice try he's a Texan whatever
something wild happen at playlist
Orlando that like there's no other we
would only tell it on the podcast but it
was like it was [ __ ] crazy
because well after that experience I was
like reminded of all the other
experiences I've had sort of similar to
that but like maybe not as I'm like dire
to sort of like explain that breed of
experience it's not our own drug stories
of things that we've done or whatever
when we're drunk it's more like we've
told about these the observing of events
with alcohol involved
we realized that we have kind of like a
handful of those stories including the
one from last weekend where we were just
like sort of bystanders of things yeah
and we watched [ __ ] go down and it was
like insane and weird and crazy so we
thought we could do a little like people
watching drunk story time for you yeah
yes
people watching for sure people watching
but at playlist Orlando which happened
what two weeks ago how long ago is that
last weekend last weekend I think so
I don't I have no concept so we had just
done like our the meat of our stuff was
on Saturday so we flew in Julian flew in
a day early to go hang out this dad what
yeah
why are you doing that hello Julian flew
in Thursday to go hang out with his dad
for a day which you guys saw in his
vlogs the video of him it's dad
hysterical in case you are curious as to
why Julian is the way that he is go
watch that video educate yourself it's
it's like looking in a mirror for you
whatever so he flew in a day early I
flew it on Friday at me and Rome and
we got there seven eight nine o'clock at
night ate some food went to bed had a
glass of wine Saturday we had a stage QA
and then I mean greet you had your PIN
booth like me and greater your PIN booth
so like we're basically up and getting
ready by like 8:00 8:30 and then gone
all day and okay what you're not gonna
do is sit in the podcast room and cry
when you're sitting on a comfortable
minion blanket so we did our army and
greet and then we're basically starving
we're so hungry like like after any mean
green so we go to mellow mushroom which
is like bless Orlando Florida but like
in that area it's one of the only places
where we can get some nice hot vegan
fried you know what's funny is like I
side story I love no mushrooms so much
like it holds such a like a dear place
my heartbeat traveling and it's your
safe place
it's your safe place amongst places
where I normally can't eat yeah I'm
wondering if it's like in my mind I've
built this pizza up to be so much better
than it actually is yeah because of what
it's around and like by comparison right
or if it's actually that good I think
it's a little bit of both a little bit
of both well oftentimes when we're
eating it Mellow Mushroom that's like
our only real meal yeah we like french
fries potato chips and broccoli all
weekend and then we get finally a pizza
pie because we found a melon mushroom in
the south which bless mellow mushroom
for existing in so many areas that
doesn't have any gluten free food or
vegan food or whatever or just options
other options but more pizza places
really need to start putting potato
slices on pizza I don't know why that's
so rare it's so delicious really good
like a baked potato pizza it's really
really good and it's mellow mushroom was
in her era you best believe I'd be
eating that [ __ ] all the time I probably
would go so we went to mellow mushroom
we had some food we had a glass of wine
and we were with Chris and Shane and
like our friends John and all the need
two people and all of Shannon's friends
like everybody was there and there was a
playlist party that night but like I was
already so exhausted Julie now we're
already pretty exhausted we hadn't even
gone to the party the night before and
I'm just like I really I'm like spent
I'm wiped like let's go back to the
hotel there's a little area outside
which remind you we've been to the same
hotel for years going to playlists and
we didn't know that there was like an
outdoor area in the downstairs lobby bar
that you could sit out we only sat in
the lobby so we were like oh I wonder
where that door goes and you could sit
outside like here this like beautiful
fire pit and like this I can't believe
we missed out on this beers so we all
went back to the hotel and there's like
a long table like all you guys are
sitting at and then me and Rome and Chan
and Marissa and Lindsay had gone and sat
by the fire and we're just sitting there
calm like no one's been drinking really
look we all have like just like starting
cuz we had dinner we had like a glass of
wine with dinner you know what I mean
like no one was drinking well it also it
was maybe 10 o'clock
maybe maybe 10 o'clock and as we hadn't
been able to sit by the fire the
previous night because they were like a
bunch of women sitting by it so we sat
at a table near it so tonight there was
just uh we got to the fire first and
there was a couple there was one couple
yeah there was like a bunch of seats
around the fire so we had a big group so
it was kind of yeah well you guys are
all sitting at the table so there was
like a a big tall bar table and there's
a bunch of people sitting at the table
it was just me Shan Rome at the fire and
then an older couple like I'd say mid
forties sitting by the fire they're like
clearly full-blown chillin she's got
like her legs up on him and he's just
sitting there like looking his phone
enjoying the fire like having a beer
relaxing so we're like trying to just be
like normal people and share a fire with
people that are clearly probably on
vacation or something you know what I
mean
so we're sitting there we're talking you
guys are at the table all hanging out
talking and all of a sudden from the
hotel lobby door I see this woman we all
see her everybody saw her she was
wearing a black dress she has like a
Louie Vuitton
sort of purse like a clutch it's flat
and she starts just like sort of
stumbling out of the hotel out into this
outdoor area she's like holding her
shoes in her hand I think at that point
and we could tell she was clearly sort
of like mess
so she sits down like a blank stare like
her eyes weren't looking any direction
you know yeah well it took her five
minutes to get from the door to the fire
which was like a very short walk but
she's just sort of like stumbling around
looking around and you know when you're
like you're not drunk you're not in like
a rowdy environment and you see someone
that's like pretty [ __ ] up
it raises everyone's like heightened
awareness of this person and okay we got
to just make sure this person isn't
gonna do anything crazy right now so she
comes she finally sits down at a chair
like directly across from Shan and I
from the fire so the couple is to our
right and Rahm is so I left and me and
Shannon are sort of facing this woman
and she sits in the chair and she's
we're all talking just relaxing and the
older couple isn't talking to us nor are
they talking to each other they're just
sitting there quietly so we're just
talking about sort of like the day and
and things and you know hanging out
she starts closing one eye and like
staring at all of us as we're talking
like really trying to listen in by
closing like I don't know if you've ever
been that drunk I've been one I do get
to where you see better when you close
one eye right so she's doing I want to
say for 20 to 25 minutes she's sitting
there across the fire from us just like
desperately trying to listen to us by
closing one eye and just to kind of
switch over to my perspective I'm at the
table the bar table next to the fire pit
so I did like all I saw from from like
of that woman was like the fact that
there was a person in that chair that
was maybe Sam T so like I assumed it was
just like a friend of the couple's like
a single person who just is just on
their phone or whatever a lot of
convention going on it just it just
didn't occur to me that it was any sort
of situation that wasn't even even
remotely bizarre because I couldn't see
it but so we're just sitting there
talking and it's been like 20 minutes
that she's been sitting there and we're
all sort of like on edge no one can sit
and address the person next to them like
hey did you see that lady like she looks
pretty messed up we should you know keep
an eye on her because she's sitting and
staring at us so all of a sudden I'm
like Shannon's telling a story or
something and I'm sort of looking in in
like Rome's direction and I hear and see
out of like the corner of my eye her
stand up and she looks over to the guy
in this couple takes her purse and slams
it on his lap like so loud it made this
like audible like really loud like like
like someone's smacking someone with a
purse yeah and he just he's remain
seated and he goes excuse me so the
second that I see I'm sorry what what oh
yeah like I'm like first of all a bunch
of things run through my mind like oh my
god I didn't realize that they knew each
other then I look at him I'm like oh my
god they don't know each other oh my god
that woman just stood up and was that
[ __ ] up she just hit that man no
reason so once I got to that point like
literally a second later I'm like this
is gonna escalate really quickly because
this is a man in his you know partner
clearly and this woman just hit him out
of the blue and watching them so I stand
up and I'm like I walk her on the fire
and I'm I'm thinking that this woman's
really drunk right so I'm like I know
how to deal with drunk people they're
like infants you got a dangle Keys in
front of him so I just I stand up and
I'm like hey why don't you come in with
me inside to hear Rome from behind me
going Jenna
like I think she thinks so like I am now
inserting myself in a situation I don't
need to yeah you were just using 10
seconds later Rome is right there with
me because she's like hey hi why don't
we bring you inside and she's holding
you're holding her shoes up like she's
got like a pair of boxing gloves
basically yes she's just ready to use
that much she goes don't you talk to me
and we're just like okay yeah why don't
we go in come on let's go meanwhile we
all turned around by then because we
like as soon as the snack happened I
remember like we were sitting that
you're getting in them they're yeah
things are happening so we turn around
and we like we're all kind of like
frozen watching it right so I like get
up and I'm kind of like next to Rome and
like on the other side of the woman just
to kind of like be there but like we're
all kind of still just like
watching because there's not much love
to do right it's like what do we do at
this point
well I roam and I were convincing her to
come in for the rest of us I was like
we're all just like I'm like I'm
thinking that this man's wife is gonna
get up in her face or like he's gonna
get in her face or like something bad is
going to escalate it might yeah yeah we
all thought she was just gonna fall into
the fire like that's what we were
mentally preparing ourselves for is that
this woman's pretty drunk she I'm scared
she's gonna fall into the fire but as
soon as I saw that go down and roams on
the same page as me it's like this could
escalate in any number of ways there's a
lot of people around here that just saw
what this woman did but we need to step
up and get her inside and get hurt like
two hotel security basically so she's
like you know not responding to us she's
doing things like don't talk to me like
really out of it so she finally like
Rome and I convinced her like Rome
mostly at one point she was like she
started looking at Rome being like okay
I trust you and I was like okay she's
got which was impressive that you guys
got her to walk into the lobby because
the lobby bar because as soon as that
happened I I told Jeff I think I told
you I was like go get security so he was
already going to get security and I was
impressed that like it didn't take
security to get her away from us you
guys actually the second that we opened
the door to go inside security was
already there and they're like we'll
take her and I'm like okay dude so we
were able to just sort of walk back out
and then we talked to that guy and we're
like do you know her like what just
happened well yeah first he's laughing
and then it's like they make him file a
police report and all that stuff so
we're all still hanging out outside we
like have a good laugh about it like
thank God everyone's okay like that
didn't escalate like nothing it was just
bizarre and apparently someone had
talked to her and she's she was in town
for a convention and here's the
terrifying part had not been drinking at
all that's one terrifying part she
wasn't drunk that's what they said they
spoke to her and she claimed and they
they form the conclusion that she had an
inner key right that's terrifying
because what the [ __ ] was she on how did
she become like completely yeah what she
had she's like a mental breakdown or
something
like I don't know - she was at a
lawyer's convention he's a lawyer
sick but like it's terrifying
yeah anyway I was like and then I sent
to the guys I was like hey like if this
ever goes to court like I know who you
can call it to be a lawyer I'm sorry it
was funny it was funny sighs yeah okay
Wow but what do you think what do you
think can happen he thinks you like it
like took the wrong meds or Odede or did
something weirder yeah I mean my my
first reaction when I see someone that
messed up is they could be on like a
prescription medication and had like a
dream in it counter yeah that's what I
thought too honestly still possible you
didn't have one drink
right and that can happen or that
somebody spiked her drink yeah that's a
scary alternative it's a terrifying
alternative regards I mean I've never
I've never like ever I don't know how
anyone would even know if they've like
interacted with someone who had been
spiked or whatever but I have no idea
what their demeanor would be like it
seems like it would be like something
like she was super myself any time like
that I'm out in the world you're
drinking or whatever if I see a girl
that's like drunk and alone I'm like
somebody needs to step in here and say
something at least say something like
are you okay yeah you've done that many
many times yeah because my first
reaction when I saw her like stumble
down in there is like at some point
tonight if I watch our walk away and she
seems okay that's fine
but like I'm not gonna leave this area
with her by herself in that state
without talking to her asking if she
needs help with anything if there's
anything you know can I help you
remember your room number or like where
you need to go do you know like I can't
in good conscience leave someone like
that like as a woman you know what I
mean I just can't but I'm it's
terrifying to me that maybe something
out of her control had happened to her
that night and then she was just like
whatever
it was crazy no like I've never watched
someone assault someone just a lot of
the Blues lately like that too
it was wild but I'm also like that that
man was incredibly patient to not just
stand up and like get in her face and be
like oh I mean like slap me with your
purse like imagine if you were her not
the drunk one or the messed up one but
the wife and someone came up to me super
[ __ ] off and just like slapped me
that's when we came back outside world
sort of like sitting early like wow I
can't believe that just happened
I look over to Roman I go if somebody
did that to Julian like that woman's
very patient I would have setup me like
you have what are you doing go why you
didn't bromb was like if that happened
to college she goes I'd take out my
phone it just was like oh man I was
trying to think in my mind of other
experiences I've had sort of like that
that was definitely one of the more like
tense ones like sort of silly and funny
yeah you know yeah but those moments it
was like and the guy afterwards you know
after we all had a good laugh or
whatever he expressed that he was
genuinely concerned because this is like
this is how someone all of a sudden is
super [ __ ] up she hits him because we
don't know why he stands up and gets
angry at her and she pulls out a gun and
[ __ ] shoots it well you just never
know yeah and like just the
unpredictability of someone who has
clearly lost the ability to decision
make so long ago to like be in your face
like that it is it is intense it isn't I
guess the police came and got her after
a while and she was getting in like the
hotel securities face everybody in
theirs face man yeah that's it was wild
I hope that she's okay honestly because
she got arrested they dragged they they
were asking her to kindly leave or go to
her room or whatever she was not
cooperating with anyone except for Jenna
in Rome yeah but then yeah they had to
arrest her apparently let her send out
in a drunk tank or whatever well yeah
but I think it's also because we weren't
trying to get her to do anything other
than just like stand up and walk
unfortunately I think
I mean the more I think about it the
more I think she was probably drugged it
seems like the most likely outcome
that's super fun can you imagine getting
arrested cuz someone drugged you like an
allele I can only do the kind of [ __ ]
that goes down to those [ __ ]
conventions yeah people just like it
anyway I have a story that wanted to
tell it's not really long or really a
story but it is sort of tea oh it's tea
I'm a fan of Parks and Rec we know and
there is an actress on the show named
Greta that's heard the name she goes by
she's pretty funny and I love her on the
show like I I love everyone in that show
but like you know she's funny like she
has moments where she's very very funny
and I wanna say like three or four years
ago no longer probably like four or five
years ago I was at a bar I was at the
surly goat in Hollywood which is a cool
bar it's definitely one of those like
the Hollywood bars it's like poppin it's
cool or just you know it's fun it gets
pretty crowded and we were there on like
a Friday or Saturday night and it was
poppin like a lot of people dancing like
waves of people trying to get to the bar
it's like your average crowded weekend
bar night and all like all of a sudden I
look over at the bar and I'm like that's
Rhetta like I see her sitting there with
her friend she was with her her friend
and I was like oh [ __ ] I was like
geeking out because I was like you know
I think back then I watched the show a
lot more than I do now so I was I was
like then that's [ __ ] cool so I like
logging in my brain I'm like okay she's
over there maybe I can go buy her shot
or approach her say hi or get a pic or
whatever something dumb right where I'm
just like maybe I could go interact and
as I'm like monitoring where she is or
like her like out of the corner of my
eye I see this this I think it was like
a dude and his girlfriend or some people
go up to her and like they were pretty
drunk and they wanted to buy her a shot
so they were like hey I like you and
they're just like trying to give her the
physical shop and she was like no no
thank you like please please no like I
don't want to
and I just saw her just basically say no
to what they were trying to offer her
which is fine like yeah like that's
normal also by the way like if you're
trying to buy someone a shot like don't
hand it to you and buy it at least let
them watch the poor tender make it like
[ __ ] so she's like they were pretty
drunk I wouldn't say they were rowdy but
they were calm so she says no and I
don't know something about that
interaction was like to me I was like oh
like that's what can go bad right like
if you interact with the wrong way with
someone you are a fan of or whatever
like don't meet your heroes have a thing
so I then went up anyway and was like
hey just want to say I'm like I'm like a
really big fan of your work
and she was like thanks and I was it and
that was it and I was like wow I
shouldn't have said anything I'm [ __ ]
stupid but she so clearly was sitting
there with a friend just desperately not
wanting to be bothered in the most like
prone environment to that sort of
situation like why are you at a popping
bar on the weekend sitting at the bar
like her responsibility to make sure
that you have a good experience with her
like she can go out and and be cold the
people if she wants to but I understand
your point where it's like you know it
would be nice if someone that you you
get the courage to go up to and say like
I'm a big fan if they were like thanks
for saying that I really yeah so just
like half turn thing I'm totally fine
with her choices to go to that bar and
say no to pictures and honestly like I
get it you want to just like to have you
but yeah just she just like didn't give
it's like thanks okay when do we leave
but I was my experience with Greta okay
I don't care I don't care the poster
ahead of her off the wall oh I had a red
no you did I didn't Julian what I bet
you could get a fatter though right if
you want probably you can if I haven't
of anything right it's just a sticker
that goes on your wall yeah I'm Fathead
calm yeah you know if I had that convo
oh my god that's probably better
ed calm because it's your own and
Squarespace allows you to make it your
home with all of their wonderful
templates all of their design elements
that you can add in a very simplified
fashion to your own website blog online
store whatever it is your domain is
yours you can customize it exactly how
you like and your if you're afraid of
building website because of the coding
and all the technical aspects
Squarespace is for you because they have
24 hours a day seven days a week
customer supports no matter what you're
trying to do your website whether you
want the panel for the menu to go over
here and over here or you want the
drop-down to go this way instead of over
here or you want the font to change but
you don't want the font to change at the
bottom
anything you want any simple tasks that
you're trying to perform on your own
website to make it exactly how you want
Squarespace is there to help you along
with you throughout the process it's
their award-winning customer support 24
hours a day think about that what other
company has customer support that lasts
through the night so when you're up at 4
a.m.
desperately trying to get something done
on your website you can just hop in and
chat with one of the Squarespace reps
and they will help you that to me is
like yes I me up dude
and right now you get an additional 10%
off of your first purchase of a website
or domain by going to Squarespace
that's squ a re SBAC e-comm slash Jenna
Julian or click the link in our video
description guys there's there's nothing
that you need to install to build it you
don't need to have coding skills nothing
like that Squarespace makes it very easy
for you and if you're looking to build
the website actually I would give it a
shot also guys keep your teeth clean in
a 20-18 fashion with quip okay clip is
the toothbrush that stays fresh because
it gives you a refill
like this
with a brand new bristle head which I'll
forget to change toothbrush heads
I know y'all do they deliver it to your
house when it's time for a new refill of
a personalized it just shows up at your
front door that the cuiprit fairy drops
it off or your UPS guy whatever it is or
your FedEx guy I don't know upside down
looks a little like it says dink right
yeah so it's basically made for the
podcast guys it's an electric toothbrush
that's award-winning but it doesn't cost
what the other toothbrushes cost all
right and it's super sleek and nice okay
this is okay and then this is the quip
head guys it's a super travel friendly
it's small is sleek it's wonderful and
right now it starts at just $25 which if
you can believe that
yeah the other toothbrushes cost
hundreds of dollars what the hell mm-hmm
all right so it gives you guided pulses
it packs into a small form-factor they
give you refills I don't know what more
you want from me right now it's a great
toothbrush and right now if you could GE
t qu IP comm get to quip comm slash
Jenna Julianne you will get your first
refill pack free so check it out or
click the link in our description to
change your toothbrush game thank you
sponsors thank you sponsors 180 special
touch it pays real quick no I don't want
to eat to face it's wrong with you be
good my next interaction with a drug
person is one that I have not been able
to forget we were just we were talking
about this after you know we were
thinking of other stories and stuff and
I feel like I have so many things that
have happened like when I was younger or
like that I remember but like I haven't
thought of in so many years that I would
have to actually like sit down and let
them come to me for hours you and I mean
like really try and jog my memory
yeah but there is one I don't know when
you're like drinking and you have
friends and then you meet their friends
right you'll sometimes stumble across
someone that you can just like never
forget I have never forgotten this
person I met him one night and one night
only and that I never saw him again
after that
why can't I forget this person you asked
let me tell you why I forget whose
mutual friend it was it was Jill's or
like my ex-boyfriends or something like
in college but I had gone over to my
friends house and they were like oh this
is my friend so-and-so and I'm like okay
this guy was like I don't remember his
name
he was one of those people that was just
like so full of energy non-stop like you
know how you're like you chillin you're
having a drink or like maybe some coke
energy or I don't know yeah like
something was he was just so over the
top and I could I guess I couldn't tell
if it was his personality or if he was
drunk or whatever yeah but he seemed
like but none of my friends did drugs so
like I didn't know why that that I guess
never crossed my mind that he was on
drugs or something like it's possible
but I think he was just like one of
those people that's just like like yeah
he's like a lot he's like a lot of a guy
and he had been drinking a lot so at one
point in the night like he's a super
nice guy seems kinda almost seems a
little out of his mind though at one
point in the night he goes I'm gonna
break my record and I'm like for what
he's like I gotta go pee pee are you
ready so he goes outside so where it's
like the house wasn't I gotta go pee pee
yes he was a weird guy so the house is
sort of like up on this hill like the
front yard was sort of sloped down to
the street I mean yeah so he walks all
the way out to the street in the street
yeah he takes off his bottoms and his
shirt
it's dark but he gets completely naked
but stay with me I have to I've told you
this before but it's like so not
significant in time like was whatever
nothing yeah he then I've never seen
anything like this in my life he goes
like this
he holds his weenus his weenus and then
all of a sudden he goes one two three
and he's like sort of squatting down
like this he lets go and like you know
when you're peeing but like you push
really hard he like like we're all just
standing up like what in the [ __ ] is
that guide to feel like pushes is pee
out and it sort of like explodes
everywhere in front of him almost but
like just like over short hard fast
dream of Pete he goes one two three does
that and he goes he's like some some
noise like yeah and then does to like
you know when you do a squat jump squat
and then jump as far as you can yeah he
did like a bunch of those and then put
his clothes back in and then came back
in the house sorry that's the most
bizarre thing that I've ever heard yeah
that's like I don't know why I would
have told you that but I like I wouldn't
doubt if I don't do that it's just that
the weirdest thing I've ever seen
there's absolutely an explanation of why
you remember that cuz it wasn't say yes
it was ridiculous like what in the world
I don't know
good pee man did you break your record
what's the record I don't know I don't
know God is it how many people saw him
how many hours before he gets arrested
I don't know he wasn't man I don't know
it was just the weirdest thing I've ever
seen what the [ __ ] yeah that's a weird
guy I could quote ibly was happening but
I feel like I was still young enough to
where you're just like alright that was
weird back to hanging out like there's
enough people there that nobody knew you
know yeah I think it was one of those
parties where you're like alright this
is my friends friend you've been hanging
he's a cool guy Wow we all saw it though
he like asked for us to go watch I'm
gonna go break my leg you know what I
bet he's doing big things
he probably is he's gotta be bottomless
to get to the top so I always say and he
started that process by being bottomless
so it's true but also I knew a kid that
got so drunk that he would like sleep
pee like you know when you like stand up
and the need pee sort of somewhere that
you think is the bathroom but your
drunkenness nerd and he had multiple
times gone over to like the VCR like the
Xbox the PlayStation and opened it
competed I wasn't there but the the kid
that I was dating at the time was and
watched him stand up go over to his
PlayStation open it pee on it you can't
wake him up right PlayStation pee in it
and then diligently press closed and
then go back to bed I don't know I would
be I would have my job on the floor I
would literally not know how to deal
with that situation how do you deal with
a situation like that
maybe you just move out of the house we
were in San Francisco there's a fun
story we were okay so we were in San
Francisco recently for the holidays for
our little Midway stop up to Oregon yeah
and we got some Attell room horrible
hotel experience we were up in this room
and we looked out the window while we
were waiting for our like we ordered
like five post mates that night because
they all [ __ ] up and none of them
worked no more you didn't get any food I
mean literally went to bed hungry was
fun well we were watching this couple
outside no so it was like a whole group
of people but it was right outside a bar
and it was this one guy who's just
losing his mind and everyone right so he
likes falling over so he for sure we're
gonna watch someone get hit by a car or
a fight break out well cuz it was the
type of fight 17 minutes of footage on
my phone cuz I was videotaping
yeah cuz I was like something Bad's
gonna happen I know something Bad's
gonna but nothing that happened I saw
but yeah he was he like he went from
like exiting the bar very like crazily
to running over to the corner it like
not the corner but like this little just
little like indent in the street and
peeing on the law we watch so many
people pee just like on this dream he
came back and they started arguing with
the bouncer and then his girlfriend was
trying to separate him with that and he
gets in a fight with his girlfriend or
this girl yeah he pushed somebody onto
something and so then him and this drunk
ass girl are like fighting and it's like
a push push battle and then all these
other girls come in and they like
instead of like breaking it all smile
they just start like falling on top of
each other yes they make this like like
people pile yeah but all of this is
happening like an inch from the street
an inch from the street in downtown Sara
was it like plenty of traffic receive so
many people out and it's late but still
it's not empty we were gonna watch
someone get hit by a car yeah really
like I wasn't videotaping it so I can
send it to worldstar if a fight broke no
yeah I was literally like somebody's
gonna need [ __ ] help and wish that
they had video evidence of what happened
yeah I want to watch that actually I
might have deleted it honestly because I
think I've realized that I didn't need
it for any reason
yeah I mean there was no real punch line
to that story but it was like definitely
like you're at the top of the hotel room
and you're just literally watching how
what alcohol can do to people just like
you were just so useless and like when I
was in falling all over the places when
I was in college and like out of college
we would go down to like Fanueil Hall
which like Boston is different now like
the areas of like where people like to
go out have changed and will continue to
change it's like it's a the nightlife
scene is very competitive like it's
though be hotspots like a bar or a club
will be hot for like a month or two and
then it's a new place you know what I
mean it's really competitive the type
the turnover I feel like it is pretty
but when I was in college like we would
always go to like Fanueil Hall which is
where all the like you could just go and
go to like four or five six seven bars
if you want like walk around there's
live music on Friday nights like it's a
rad place but people get so sloppy
yeah and Boston is just like the there's
so many colleges nearby there's so many
students there's so many people and
they're like early to mid-20s that it's
like once 2 a.m. hits and the bars are
closed
it's like fireworks out on the street
like you're going to watch a fight
happen you know what I mean in the
street especially if it's the summertime
yeah yeah it was wild like I feel like
I've watched a million times people all
of a sudden they're just like I'm
outside time to punch somebody what the
hell man mm-hmm
whatever anyways I haven't seen that in
Los Angeles almost ever that's I don't
think it's the only thing people you
don't fight that much they really don't
I mean they fight in the sense that like
people this is like bringing me back to
like bartending days and like how I'm
just being around drunk dumb asses all
the time people just hear people like to
get really drunk and like like touch
your shoulder and then like
passive-aggressive fight and then
they're like they're out of there yeah
but in Boston I know that people are
looking for fights all the time I know
that it's like a Boston thing I get it
I'm gonna try to stereotype earning but
it definitely is not the same it's not
the same vibe with people like people
get aggressive here people get
aggressive everywhere but the general
theme is not like that right well I'm in
Boston there's there are plenty of like
I personally knew people that would get
in bar fights you know II mean it's like
a thing but they wouldn't go to jail
unless somebody got really [ __ ] hurt
or something you know what I mean I just
each other off and you leave yeah they
run away and then yeah they're boys
[ __ ] yellow there are other boys and
then you know it's squashed or something
we wake up while you're getting brunch
and you talk about next yeah it's like a
funny thing but like here I feel like no
one gets in fights because the police
would get called immediately and
somebody would be suing another person
you know that's not far off either I
think people would would do yeah the
people here aren't out drinking to get
in a fight where's like there's plenty
of places in the United States where
people go out drinking
and they just want to get in a fight
some people just looking for trouble
though there's always those people chin
I know that there's more of these like
story drunk watching stories but what
about the time I wanted to hear about
the time with the when the cops came oh
yeah really story so um my best friend
growing up Brandon as you guys know he
passed away recently but there were so
many good stories with him because he
was just so funny and he was just down
for whatever like he was always excited
to do it like take on any adventure or
like go to any party no matter if it was
like [ __ ] close or all the way it
sounds central where the [ __ ] he didn't
care he was just like down for a good
time he always wanted like you know be
be out there with his friends and
whatever so we decided one night and I
believe we were either seniors in high
school or like freshmen in college but
we decided to go to this party in
Beverly Hills and we didn't grub him
everything else we grew up in like Santa
Monica and I grew up partly in Culver
City so like Beverly Hills to us was
like the nice area it was like there all
the kids who were like I know I know I
know that but I mean like we played them
in high school yeah in sports and stuff
so we like had this rivalry with them
because they were like the rich kids or
whatever right but we just had to go to
a party over there and I don't even
remember who we knew I don't even think
we really know anyone I think we just
had like a friend of a friend who was
there so he could get us in a house
party yeah so you go to this house party
in Beverly Hills and we don't know
anyone we're just like hanging out and
it's like the weirdest time and maybe
like 45 minutes into us being there the
cops show up and break it all up as they
do in the high school early college
parties they just like show up and then
it's like party's over everybody I know
and as the cops come in and start you
know in filing people out and like
alright guys music off lights on yeah
we're in the backyard and the cops are
like right there there's a pool right
and so we're like around the pool and
the cops are like walking around the
pool playing clear us all out
and while everyone's walking out the
music's off like everyone's just like
kind of bummed it's like alright nights
over whatever I hear behind me brain and
just start singing at the top of his
lungs and we're just I turn around and
me and Andrew are we like are like
crying laughing because he can't believe
that not only is he just like making a
complete fool of himself and it's
hilarious but he's doing right like at
the cops cops have to listen to this
idiots singing at them and we're just
like oh my I was so funny and it's just
like they arrest him it made our night
because he was doing nothing wrong he
was just singing that was like the
epitome of like going somewhere that
wasn't fun or really cool and making it
really fun and stupid because that's
what he did but yeah that was I will
literally never hear that song again and
not think of that story because that is
so like it is such a funny story such a
funny night it was also like very
passive-aggressive because we like
didn't like Beverly Hills in the cop
show that's we didn't care I'm sure you
guys got invited back immediately y'all
meet so many new friends who we were I
used to have parties like that in
college because well first softball we
have a 48-hour drinking role so you
can't drink within 48 hours before us
before or after a game or practice when
you practice well before before so yeah
that's not like after your game you just
go get drunk yeah no no but we couldn't
do that ever
like all fall we are playing the winter
we go home for break and you have to
work out or even drink over winter break
but like all season it's like you know
the first thing we would do is sit down
and crunch out our schedule and be like
here's the night when we can party
here's the night where we can party and
all of our games are doubleheader so we
would play two games a day but um we
would have very specific times when we
could like drink and finally let loose
really so we would throw parties at our
apartment and way that the baseball
house and there's always just people
that roll up and you're like no [ __ ]
idea
who you are yeah and also because we
didn't have a campus we just lived in
the middle of Cambridge you'd get an
occasional just bizarro neighbor walk
over and be like sup guys I'm like we
would have to get one of our big tall
guy friends to be like excuse me sir you
can't be here there's like there's 21
year old girls here get out what are you
doing you know but we had a problem
though too we had girls that would come
in and want to do drugs in our bathroom
oh what'd you do for the people who
would want to do come yeah we knew about
a group of girls that was like honey
first of all it's bad enough that we can
like have a drink you know what I mean
because we're student-athletes we're not
we didn't break any rules but like you
know what I mean
we don't also don't want to get caught
drinking or having a party letting some
same life exactly but so none of us
[ __ ] with any drugs like not okay not
you can't and you can get kicked off the
dinner for sure easily without a
question it's a contention illegals
across the board so there was [ __ ] a
group of girls that would hang out with
the baseball kids that we knew did coke
and they we had a four-bedroom apartment
and whenever we'd throw parties there's
one bathroom one toilet and then it
would just be packed with people and so
inevitably it would just be like closed
all night you can never get in there go
to the bathrooms and people try and pee
outside and I'm like dude stop it like
who the cops are gonna come stop peeing
in our yard and weird [ __ ] so we knew
that this group of girls would go in
there cuz we've had a problem with them
a couple of times where they would go in
there and after one other party my
friend Ashley was like I think they did
[ __ ] drugs in the bathroom like no
way no way cuz we're cleaning up after
you and she's like I think that they
were in there cuz they were in there for
half an hour like four or five of them
yeah more like banging on the door like
people have to go to the bathroom get
the [ __ ] out what do you do know you so
the next day she was like I'm pretty
sure that those girls were doing drugs
in here and I'm like naive super naive
but I'm like absolutely not like what do
you mean I don't know anybody that
[ __ ] does drugs no way they wouldn't
be allowed in my house
as if people who did drugs were a sign
on their forehead that were like
drugs so my friend Ashley was like all
right I got a plan and I'm like okay I'm
down what's the plan she was like let's
put vaseline on the back because there's
no surface and there's a shitty like the
sink is just like a thing there's no
surface area the only surface area was
the back of the toilet and she was at
the top of it and she goes let's put
Vaseline all over the top of that so if
anyone comes in here and tries to do
drugs they're [ __ ] so go all right
easy enough so we cover the top of the
toilet with Vaseline and later that
night
that group of girls I will not say her
[ __ ] name but like um she comes from
a long line of last names that are very
yeah I'll tell you tell me I get the
nagging - yes yeah but her and all her
rich little girlfriends went in there
like I'm not kidding you
like five minutes later they stormed out
of the bathroom and left the party
stormed out of there they were they were
furious they were yelling they were
screaming and we were all just like
Babbage my friend Ashley was right they
was doing drugs don't do drugs kids
don't go to someone's house that has one
bathroom and stand in it for a half an
hour and do drugs get out of here that's
that's [ __ ] cool that you just like
you brought the law in your own hands
well it was Ashley it was my friend
Ashley she did it mommy Ashley the one I
know right yeah you'd met her yeah she's
cool that's funny sorry it's a good
story it's really not but that's a good
story
if you if you're a young person that
sometimes has house parties where it's
one of those things where friends invite
friends or people show up that you don't
know and you think someone's gonna be
doing drugs find out a way to ruin their
time and then they'll just leave and
you're not even being a narc I'm not an
R I know not my cut what my brother
looks like a cop I though I would have
loved to call the police on them
[ __ ] that whatever my brother was when
we golf the other day my brother's
wearing these aviators and he's a
mustache now he looks like a straight-up
cop yeah he does look like an exacto he
does with his mustache and his ginger
beard well ladies we began the podcast
and we ended it
Amar's Jesus Christ
well thank you guys for hanging out for
another episode and listening to us if
you'd like to listen to us for hours and
hours and hours more talking and
laughing and goofing go to our Twitter
channel we stream all the [ __ ] time
then it's great yeah it is great and
it's just like it yo soy peligro
conscious stream of conscious change a
how we're playing no we're playing games
during that though um you guys have a
wonderful week we'll see you on the next
one don't do drugs to track your pugs TM
[Music]